la discothèque sanctuaire où le common
entre pas mûres qu'aucune lamentations
ne sauraient ébranler de la lumière dans
la nuit à paris dans le sud en
normandiez partout ailleurs des
discothèques ouvre dans les années 50
la recette de la musique des
déhanchements et de la boisson années 60
oblige ça twist sur la piste sur les
banquettes ou pas du tout c'est plutôt
peut regarder le triste lot la première
je l'apprends visuellement oui parce que
j'ai une femme et ça me donne des
crampes d'estomac
jusqu'à ce que bien rapidement la mode
passe au madison
après les balles et les bar dansant la
discothèque devient dans les villes une
nouvelle expérience de sorties nocturnes
et dansante lieu du lâcher prise propice
à la séduction les boîtes de nuit c'est
aussi une affaire de mode un lieu
branché en remplace un autre
en 1978 à paris c'est le début des
années palace cet ancien théâtre devenue
repaire des noctambules dans le coup
plutôt sélect web a pas de regret parce
que j'aimais me bass quatre cheminées
basket et va pas me suis rentré à
l'époque on n'est pas à la hauteur des
dettes qui leur plaît la fête se
scénographie le travail de dj
s'accompagne de lumière de laser de
danseurs vous la facette et disco dans
les années 70 pour des jeunes en
recherche de celle évasion une manière
décontractée enfin j'ai pas besoin de
mecs
pourquoi sa liberté totale
les boîtes de nuit ont connu leur âge
d'or dans les années 80 avec 4000
établissements dans toute la france
depuis leur nombre a progressivement
diminué
il en reste aujourd'hui 1200
[Musique]